bonjour jean marc bonjour on a entendu
évidemment emmanuel macron hier qui
s'est dit confiant dans la solidité de
la reprise de l'économie si évidemment
les gestes barrières sont respectées est
ce que ça veut dire que cette possible
cinquième vague pourrait remettre en
cause à la reprise de l'économie
écoutez c'est un peu ce qu'on a compris
en filigramme il a fait a quand même un
très très long discours très articulé il
est parti du coc vide pour passer
ensuite à la situation économique parce
que dans son dos logiciel tout est à peu
près ailier alors on sait peu de choses
sur l'ampleur de cette cinquième vague
qui se forment à l'étranger dans
certains pays notamment de l'europe de
l'est temps réussi en allemagne on voit
bien qu'en allemagne à une recrudescence
également on voit qu'elle paraît assez
contenue en france c'est vrai mais le
taux de contamination augmente donc le
président de la république a allumé les
warnings c'est ce qu'il a fait hier là
dessus et finalement il nous a dit trois
choses la première c'est que kovy des
dangereux
le souk mais il est sous contrôle donc
il faut pas desserré des mesures qui ont
marché d'où la troisième dose de
vaccination qu'il impose d'ailleurs
quasiment à tous ceux qui vont avoir
plus de 65 ans 2 la situation économique
est les meilleurs bien meilleure
beaucoup meilleur que ce que l'on
craignait donc sous-entendu de quoi le
quoi qu'il en coûte il a là aussi
fonctionner mais le troisième point et
il faut tout faire pour éviter les
confinements parce que ce sont des
confinement qui déstabilisent l'économie
et qu'ils arrêtent l'activité s'est pas
de virus qui a mis en difficulté
l'économie c'est sur les mesures qui ont
été prises pour contrer le virus alors
pour répondre à votre question la
reprise économique ne sera pas menacé si
on poursuit l'effort de vaccination
parce que on sait que c'est laversines
actions qui nous protège il faut donc
continuer de faire attention avec le
fameux gel avec les masques alors ils
utilisent la méthode qu'il a déjà
utilisé la vaccination n'est pas
obligatoire sauf que pour certaines
activités eh bien il faudra être
vaccinés cette méthode a très bien
fonctionné jusqu'à maintenant faut le
reconnaître
et depuis trois jours les appels dans
les centres de vaccination ont explosé
tout le monde sent bien il faut le faire
et que il faut pas prendre trop de
retard là dessus et à propos de la
situation économique beaucoup
d'observateurs pensent que la reprise
actuelle née renée le cul le résultat
d'un rattrapage et cette embellie risque
de retomber quels sont les risques d
souffert et écoute et l'ampleur de la
reprise actuelle est athée assez
surprenante un stade ça a surpris tout
le monde en bas sans doute terminer
l'année 2000 21 avec un taux de
croissance record on va avoisiner les 7
% actuellement on est à 6 7% c'est à
dire qu'on a plus que rattrapé les
pertes dues coville le taux d'emploi est
très bon avec un chômage qui est
historiquement bas il ya moins de
faillites qu'avant alors que beaucoup
nous annonçait une catastrophe sociale
la bourse est bonne les mêmes trop bonne
pour certains et des indicateurs sont au
vert pour l'année prochaine 2022 ça
devrait fonctionner actuellement
l'activité les tirée par
l'investissement des entreprises tout ça
c'est le résultat des plans de soutien
des plans de relance donc on verra
l'année prochaine mais il faudra que la
consommation relais cet investissement
parce que actuellement la consommation
est encore assez molle on sent que la
confiance n'est pas encore revenue dans
la population le mois de décembre va
être décisif pour ça pour juger de la
situation parce que les chiffres de
décembre en matière de consommation sont
en général des terminaux pas vous
raconter ce qui va se passer on en
reparlera noël en tout cas il ya quand
même un problème de pouvoir d'achat jean
marc puisque ça apparaît comme la
première inquiétude des français oui
c'est effectivement ce qui ressort des
sondages mais il faut être très prudent
globalement parce que macro économique
où on s'aperçoit que le pouvoir d'achat
n'a pas baissé en france c'est même
d'ailleurs un des rares pays où il n'a
pas baissé cependant le sentiment
d'avoir perdu en pouvoir de dépenser est
très réelle parce qu'il ya un problème
sur l'énergie parce que le pétrole parce
que le gaz passe à l'électricité ont
augmenté très vite avec la reprise et
que certaines catégories de la
population ne voit très bien quand il
faut payer la facture mais la demande
sur ces produits là est aussi très forte
alors je crois qu'en réalité les risques
de bugs sur la croissance sont ailleurs
il ya un problème de pénurie sur
certains produits industriels qu'on ne
trouve plus on trouve plus de puces
électroniques par exemple ce qui bloque
complètement la construction automobile
c'est très difficile de pouvoir acheter
une voiture aujourd'hui il faut attendre
plusieurs mois on ne trouve plus de
ciment pour les chantiers par exemple il
ya beaucoup de chantiers qui sont
bloqués à cause de ça et puis on a un
problème de pénurie de main d'oeuvre
alors ça dans beaucoup de secteurs dans
le bâtiment dans la restauration a
beaucoup de restaurateurs qui le dit ce
qu'il trouve personne pour travailler et
et dans le digital notamment et là ça
concerne tout le monde je crois que
l'année 2022 va être décisive parce
qu'il va falloir que la consommation
reparte et que les exportations elle
redémarre quand jean marc est ce qu'une
bonne situation économique autorise le
président à reprendre les réformes à
écouter tranquillement doucement il nous
a amené à faire de la politique
finalement parce qu'il en a fait la
réussite de la bataille contre le coc
vide c'est ce qu'il a dit le bilan du
poids qu'il en coûte tout ça lui ont
donné visiblement des ailes pour
annoncer des projets qui sont très
importants et qui sont très sensible
dans l'opinion a le premier projet s'est
renforcé la valeur travail ça a été la
colonne vertébrale de son discours il a
dit et répété qu'on ne s'en sortira que
si l'on travaille un peu plus il faut
travailler davantage travailler plus
longtemps et c'est vrai il y a trois
millions de chômeurs dans ce pays c'est
paradoxal alors qu'il ya énormément de
jobs qui sont qui ne trouve pas preneur
d'où le renforcement des incitations et
même des obligations de travail et alors
là il a été très strict et très
déterminé on peut se demander d'ailleurs
comment les syndicats vont réagir mais
je pense qu'ils vont pas tarder à le
faire deuxième projet renforcer
l'indépendance de la france à commencer
par l'énergie d'où l'annoncé ça c'est
assez spectaculaire de la reprise du
programme nucléaire c'est la première
fois depuis trente ans qu'un président
ose dire qu'il faut investir dans le
nucléaire sinon ben on est on est
dépendant des puissances étrangères or
le nucléaire qui est décarbonée nous
fournit aujourd'hui en que 70% de
l'électricité et le reste des autres
énergies ne pourra pas de nantes
notamment l'énergie naturelle avant sauf
investissements colossaux compenser
poussa alors il a aussi déroulé des
réformes ça vous a pas échappé à plus
long terme sur les retraites par exemple
mais il a aussi abordé la france dans
l'europe puisqu'il a rappelé qu'ils
seraient président de l'europe au 1er
janvier et puis dans le monde et là on a
bien compris qu'il était rentré en
période électorale il est rentré assez à
l'aise en fixant des priorités la
pandémie bien sur l'économie et le
travail je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué il a parlé d'immigration qui
quand même le sujet sur lequel la france
débattait bah ça change un peu lisse
comme il a cadré ce que serait pour lui
sans doute la campagne électorale le cap
à tenir à venir